as anyone who's been paying attention
can see crypto currencies have been
taking a big hit lately dropping in
prices and losing billions of dollars in
value but what's really interesting is
as that's happening companies from all
over the world are starting to take a
renewed interest in the underlying
blockchain technology these big
enterprises are looking for other ways
that they can move value from one point
to another using a blockchain without
unnecessary middlemen if you look back
over the history of blockchain adoption
that the first use case was Bitcoin the
crypto currency and it's big selling
point was that anybody could use it and
you could move value from point A to
point B without any middlemen the
downside to that though is that the
transactions were all out there for
anybody to see
it only took a little bit of work for
people to start to triangulate who these
identities were and to learn about how
these transactions were being used now
for a big enterprise this just can't
happen not only to protect the privacy
zuv they're their customers but for
regulatory reasons there's actually
controls in place to ensure that these
big enterprises aren't letting our
information just go out into the world
willy-nilly so they're reaching out to
third-party software providers who are
creating these permissioned block chains
and building whole new ways of doing
business that let them move everything
from money to records of tuna
transactions using a shared distributed
ledger without the unnecessary middlemen
the biggest difference between these
permissioned block chains that
enterprises are increasingly becoming
comfortable with and the permission list
block chains is where the source of
trust comes from in a permissionless
blockchain like Bitcoin and aetherium
the trust comes from two pretty simple
factors mathematics and electricity but
the downside to that is because you're
trusting these outside sources
mathematics and electricity the
transactions tend to be a little more
easy to view now for enterprises the
group of people that need
access to these blockchains is a lot
smaller this is what's called a trusted
setup or an invitation-only setup which
is why the block chains themselves are
frequently called permissioned now
what's really interesting though is that
these two worlds the the permissioned
world and the permissionless world
aren't diametrically opposed they're
actually on a spectrum and you can have
different degrees of permission and
privacy depending on who you are and
what you build so what's happening now
that these big enterprises are getting
increasingly comfortable with using
permissioned block chains is they're
starting to learn new ways where they
can use public block chains and the
increased efficiency that comes from
that but in a way that still protects
their users privacy and hopefully
complies with regulatory concerns
so because permission lists block chains
like Bitcoin were inherently financial
in the beginning most of the use cases
out there are indeed financial but
what's really interesting as a broader
sector of enterprises get involved as
we're seeing all kinds of different ways
that blockchain can be used in fact in
the end what blockchain really is is
just a way to prove that you've moved
something from one place to another and
so we've seen companies like bumblebee
tuna that has a long history of
difficulty proving the origin of its
tuna use blockchain to give consumers
increased a certainty that what they're
eating is in fact what they believe
they're eating more importantly that was
captured in a way that they find ethical
while bumblebee is found is that to get
the tuna from one place to another
requires a lot of levels of the supply
chain and in order to give their end
consumer that increase in certainty that
their fish hasn't accidentally captured
something that was unintended or that it
was done in an immoral way they've got
to gather all the data about how it was
captured and and given it to their
customers the problem with that solution
is that it still relies on trust in
bumblebee and Bumblebee isn't a data
company so what they did is they used a
blockchain to give every level of the
supply
I chain from the fishermen to the
packagers to the Kanner's to the
shippers to the grocery stores access to
the same distributed ledger so you don't
have to trust bumblebee anymore
you can actually see into the core of
the underlying supply chain and if there
is any fraud if there is any concern we
know exactly where it came from and
instead of the feeling of being
powerless we can know exactly how to fix
it another really interesting enterprise
use case of blockchain is golden state
foods they provide food for some of the
biggest fast-food chains in the world
including McDonald's so what golden
state foods has done is they've actually
moved the entire beef supply chain that
goes into their hamburger process to a
shared distributed ledger they're taking
what's essentially boring accounting
software and adding on all kinds of fun
bells and whistles for example the boxes
that hold the hamburgers have
thermometers in them and RFID chips and
the data is logged on the blockchain so
that you can literally see as an object
moves from one place to another as one
person takes custody over the burgers
you can be assured that the temperature
of those hamburgers hasn't gone too high
or hasn't gone too low if you're trying
to prove that the food was never frozen
what's really important about this is
for companies that want to be able to
charge more for premium services like
for example that their meat was never
frozen can now prove beyond the shadow
of a doubt that in fact the meat was
never frozen in other words by using a
blockchain by moving that supply chain
to a shared distributed ledger we no
longer have to trust golden state foods
or McDonald's that that hamburger meat
has never been frozen we can trust the
blockchain one of the most valuable
aspects of these enterprises adopting
blockchain technology is they've given
us a new way to talk about this
technology cryptocurrency was inherently
and is inherently difficult to
communicate the value of enterprise
adoption of blockchain
letting us track things that we can hold
in our hands and in some cases even put
in our mouths once we have that real
world connection to how these products
impact us and we start to go backwards
to see how removing unnecessary
middlemen can both speed up the rate
that we're able to take care of business
and let us do it cheaper the benefits of
blockchain become much more easy to
understand as enterprises get
increasingly comfortable with using
these permission block chains I'd be
keeping your eyes open for them to start
exploring other ways to use
permissionless block chains like Bitcoin
and aetherium to do the same thing but
with new imaginative ways to protect
their customers identities
you
[Music]